ti guillaumat si guillaume mayer en
direct de nevers donc la liste de denis
thériault qui arrive en tête et qui donc
décroche la mairie de nevers et cette
situation intéresse au premier chef
françois sauvadet pour lui dit alors
faut-il enlever l'étiquette udf pour
être sûr de marquer des points françois
sauvadet non mais il est bon
la victoire chez les soutenir moi je
suis très bon vous laisse j'ai soutenu
il était candidat udb oui je sais bien
mais gégé j'étais de ceux qui ont plaidé
d'ailleurs sur votre plateau je pas
subventionner la semaine dernière sur
votre plateau j'ai appelé des trois
listes à s'unir pour faire en sorte
qu'ils une alternative à nevers nevers
en fait c'est la fin d'un système là bas
les gens n'en pouvais plus enfin une
espèce de transmission de flambeau
permanente manque de respiration une
vitrine qui a perdu huit mille habitants
une douzaine d'années sur les sur place
enfin franchement il y avait une
inspiration changement il fallait rendre
le changement possible et donc nous
avons rendu le changement possible et
moi chaque fois qu on se rassemblera
autour d'un projet pour rendre le
changement possible et préparer des
conditions d'une alternance politique je
serai là pour les aider pour la
compagnie doit vous dire j'ai tout fait
pour cette fusion coupe donc vous
revendiquez l'angleterre jonny est sinon
je la revendique pas d'abord c'est la
victoire de tenir thuriau et toute sa
liste moi je dis bravo denis courage
continuez ouvrez donner de l'air un peu
et de la respiration adverse en a bien
besoin mettez de l'économie au coeur de
tout cela est en tout cas s'être c'est
plein de promesses pour l'avenir des
neuf et reçoit j'en suis convaincu